[Música]
en 1930 y 1961 miles de personas fueron
encarceladas torturadas y asesinadas
bajo la dictadura de Rafael Trujillo en
la República Dominicana
Tres hermanas encabezaron una Revolución
clandestina pero aunque su valentía
inspiró a muchos esta amenazaba al
hombre en el poder y sus vidas pronto
tendrían un final trágico
Trujillo ascendió de los rangos
militares durante la ocupación de los
Estados Unidos en la República
Dominicana tomó el poder en 1930
mediante un golpe de estado y una
elección amañada y creó un sistema que
lo enriquecía a él y a sus aliados la
familia de Trujillo sola controlaba tres
quintos del producto interior bruto
incluyendo monopolios de sal carne de
res y periódicos le puso su nombre a la
capital del país y deseaba que su
retrato se mostrara en todas las casas
y cometió atrocidades incluyendo la
masacre de miles de haitianos Mientras
tanto una fuerza de policía secreta
mantenía su poder intimidando a sus
oponentes en el país y en el extranjero
las hermanas mirabal crecieron en una
familia de clase media en el campo sus
padres enviaron a las cuatro hermanas
patria dd Minerva y María Teresa a uno
de los mejores internados del país
allí Minerva tuvo un amigo cuyo familiar
fue asesinado por órdenes de Trujillo
ella comenzó a buscar fuertes voces
opositoras y a discutir los problemas de
opresión y Justicia con sus hermanas
desde ese mantuvo fuera de la política
pero Minerva Patria y María Teresa se
dedicaron a cambiar a su país sin
embargo la seguridad de la familia
mirabal pronto colapsó en 1949 fueron
invitadas a una de las fiestas de
Trujillo
las cuales le funcionaban como terreno
de cacería de mujeres jóvenes declinar
la invitación no era una opción pese a
los intentos de Minerva para eludirlo en
la recepción finalmente bailó con
Trujillo pero rechazó sus insinuaciones
la familia mirabal abandonó la fiesta
temprano lo cual casi nadie hacía y se
consideraba una falta de respeto al
dictador
su padre Enrique fue encarcelado y la
propiedad de la familia confiscada
Minerva se graduó con los más altos
honores al ser la primera mujer del país
en recibir un título en leyes pero se le
negó la autorización del Estado para
ejercerlo algo de lo que Trujillo se
encargó cuando estudiaba Minerva conoció
a Manolo tabares justo él compartía sus
convicciones políticas y se casaron en
1955 ellos vieron brotar las
revoluciones armadas en toda América
Latina después de que Trujillo
quebrantara un intento para derrocarlo
en 1959 ellos comenzaron a preparar su
propia Revolución las hermanas mirabal y
sus esposos crearon el movimiento
revolucionario 14 de junio junto con
muchos otros de clase media
apodadas las mariposas las tres
organizaron y asistieron a reuniones
clandestinas y distribuyeron panfletos
que detallaban las violaciones de
Trujillo
en enero de 1960 juntaron a
representantes de todo el país para
establecer la infraestructura del
movimiento y preparar una revuelta pero
esta nunca ocurriría Trujillo tenía
espías por todos lados pronto muchos
revolucionarios incluidas Minerva y
María Teresa fueron arrestados Durante
este tiempo patria descubrió formas
creativas de transmitir información de y
para los Rebeldes encarcelados temeroso
de perder el apoyo de los Estados Unidos
y la iglesia que recientemente había
comenzado a criticarlo Trujillo liberó a
las hermanas pero mantuvo a los esposos
encarcelados pero ella siguieron
amenazando la estabilidad de su régimen
y su ego el 25 de noviembre cuando las
Tres hermanas regresaban de visitar a
dos de sus esposos en cárcel los hombres
de Trujillo detuvieron el auto las
hermanas y el conductor Rufino de la
cruz fueron asfixiados y golpeados hasta
morir los hombres volcaron el jeep desde
una colina para hacerlo parecer un
accidente patria tenía 36 Minerva 33 y
María Teresa 25
pero el plan de Trujillo para silenciar
a las hermanas mirabal resultó
contraproducente mucha gente no se dejó
engañar por ese encubrimiento endeble la
comunidad internacional condenó el
asesinato Estados Unidos cerró su
embajada dominicana e investigó
secretamente el movimiento anti Trujillo
meses más tarde antiguos miembros de la
milicia dominicana mataron al dictador
lo que puso fin a 31 años de Violento
mandato gracias a su familia en especial
a su hermana sobreviviente dd el legado
de las hermanas mirabal superó a Las
garras de la tiranía de Trujillo incluso
mucho después de su muerte hoy en día
las hermanas mirabal Son heroínas
nacionales como monumentos en su honor
que conmemoran su lucha en 1999 las
Naciones Unidas declararon el 25 de
noviembre el aniversario de sus muertes
el Día Internacional de la eliminación
de la violencia contra la mujer su
valiente lucha por la justicia ha
inspirado a generaciones
[Música]
para conocer otra historia de una mujer
que luchó contra la autoridad y se
enfrentó a una dura oposición aprenda
sobre la vida de Sor Juana Inés de la
Cruz Y por qué fue censurada por la
iglesia católica con este video